[Music]
Oh kudos president Trump and his
administration for letting the cameras
in and continuing that conversation that
every cable channel took an interaction
with family members students who
survived that shooting in Florida
previous shootings family members
principals of schools dealing with
school security and there was a lot of
emotion in those couple of hours I lost
the best friend was practically a
brother and I'm here to use my voice
because I know he can it doesn't make
sense fix it should have been one school
shooting and we should have fixed it and
I'm pissed because my daughter I'm not
gonna see again she's not here she's not
here very amazing emotion and now the
fight for solutions let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Amy Walter national editor for the cook
Political Report and Jonathan Swan
national political reporter for Axios
byron I was struck by just first of all
the the whole event and the fact that we
were listening in on this exchange it
did cover all sides it clearly was not
one side or the other it reminded me of
that cabinet meeting where you saw the
open exchange of lawmakers but this had
the added emotional factor of parents
who had just lost a loved one this past
week it did and the president did a good
thing by simply let letting these people
tell their stories there were a whole
variety of suggestions or all variety of
experiences that people had had with
with violence and I think the president
clearly wants to be seen as getting
ahead of this issue of actually
considering taking some action on this
that's why he did this today is why did
the bump stock thing yesterday not sure
he actually has the authority to do that
but he did it anyway and what remains to
be seen though was what exactly would he
be behind what in terms of what action
he seems clearly to be in favor of or
thinking about the favoring raising the
rate age for buying a long gun to 21 as
it is for a handgun to some sort of
enhance background checks but the
question I think a big debate will be
about assault weapons yeah that's always
what this comes down to yeah the
president tweeting on background checks
last night whether we are Republican or
Democrat we must now focus on
strengthening background checks he also
listen to one father's solution today
one possible solution which may not be
very popular would be to have people in
the school teachers administrators who
have volunteered to have a firearm
safely locked in the classroom who are
given training throughout the year have
them raise their hands to volunteer for
the training and when something like
this starts the first responders are
already on campus you know there was
some pushback in that room Amy about
that we are now learning tonight just
moments ago that armed sheriff's
deputies are going to be patrolling the
area around the school down there where
this incident happened as of tomorrow or
this week well this is always the
challenge on an issue like this and as
we saw even on immigration where if you
ask the broad question do you support
background checks you get almost
universal support do you support
allowing these daca recipients to stay
in the country almost universal support
then you get into the details of this
which is if we there were just a bill
simply that talked about background
checks with nothing else added if
Republicans added on something about
arming allowing teachers or other
volunteers to be armed there was in
another bill this idea of that
Republicans had to about a concealed
carry issue that is going to destroy any
ability to get Democrats on board if
Democrats push too far on limiting
access to assault rifles that's going to
push it nobody seems capable of simply
saying we're gonna solve this one
problem we're not gonna solve all of it
we're gonna just be able to do this one
thing pass it and start it you know was
compelling I thought on the argument for
arming people inside the school whether
it's teachers or or some trained person
like an Air Marshal that you don't know
is in there was the the father who lost
the daughter who said after 9/11 we
figured it out we as a country changed
things and we figured it out but after
Columbine we didn't figure it out and
school shooting after school shooting we
haven't figured it out it's because the
left and the right have have different
ideas about what gun control means and
there was this debate in the 90s early
nineties you know if you talked to
Grover Norquist about it he'll tell you
chapter and verse
where the left was saying we want a list
of everyone who owns a gun and the right
will say no we want a list of the bad
people that we want to prevent from
having guns and and then now it's the
same debate it's the left wants to
reduce the number of firearms in this
country and put limits on them and the
right wants more security and again
there's very little overlap on this
issue particularly when it comes to
something like arming people in schools
this is something that the president
instinctively is actually in favor of
arming literally he was nothing but but
he's also all over the map
he's privately saying in Barnes ride and
we've reported it you know
kids shouldn't be allowed to have guns
we should raise the age to 21 that's
never gonna fly it's never gonna fly
with the NRA they've pretend pushing it
and gets the NRA to the table and says
listen we got to do something they will
never support that and if he if he got
right behind that he could he could get
a 60 votes probably in the Senate
Democrats and maybe some squishes but
you ain't getting nothing through the
house speaking of the house here's Nancy
Pelosi and Paul Ryan on the background
check bill all we've been asking to the
speaker is to give us a vote we believe
there is bipartisan support for
improving as a background check bill we
had hearings on the gaps in the instant
check system and those hearings led to a
conclusion that the work gaps that need
to be fixed and that led to legislation
that has been now passed the house we
passed legislation cleaning up the
instant cheque background check system
that bill with others is sitting over
the United States Senate all right barn
so I guess well there's a lot of emotion
here there's a lot of passion it does
seem like it's a different conversation
but in reality what are we going to see
I don't know if it really is a different
conversation I mean Trump has to set
himself apart from this dysfunctional
history of this I mean personally
looking at it if they didn't do anything
after Newtown I mean someone went in and
murdered 20 first graders they didn't
know anything after Newtown how are they
gonna do anything now because you have a
Republican president who has the backing
of the NRA who could be a Nixon in China
on the issue of guns after Newtown there
was a vote on banning assault weapons
Democrats controlled the Senate 55 45 16
Democrats voted against it there was a
bipartisan consensus not sure that has
completely changed even on bump stocks
after Las Vegas and even when the NRA
gave them permission to do something
about bump stocks they didn't do it
alright quantity I could have pol gun
control options required background
checks support you see these numbers in
these polls mandatory waiting period for
gun purchases nationwide assault weapons
ban and we saw the reaction from the
Clinton assault weapons ban and that
their own Justice Department kind of
listed why that didn't work then
stopping school shootings as an
electoral issue is this going to drive
the day that is really an interesting
question given the emotionality around
this but also the activism by younger
voters is this going to activate
those young voters who traditionally sit
out midterm elections it's really
unclear one thing we do know just
historically it's people who own guns
tend to be much more passionate and
engaged politically on the issue than
people who don't undergo ants it's
almost a two to one difference people
who say they called their member of
Congress to talk about this issue or has
you know they've tweeted about it or
engaged somehow about it are we gonna
see a change now on the other side and
where and we don't know that yet also
have we ever I mean I don't know the
answer this question you probably do in
your program the only people who does
has there ever been a candidate who has
won an election on a gun control message
that that was the decisive factor that
got them of the newark congress race
what was her name yeah in on Long Island
anyway
Mahoney McCarthy excellent right I got
to tell you that they told it in my ear
question you could just do chapter and
verse pick the state pick the year I
mean there are 16 milk more than 60
million people who have concealed carry
permits in this country they care about
it it's an issue I gotta run but down
the road does something happen
legislatively with Trump pushing it I
think something happens but it's it's
modest
it's very skeptical that anything
happens hottest modest okay panel thank
you